hello I'm Doug Walker I'm Rob Walker and
this is sibling rivalry so okay after
years and years of trying to avoid the
Twilight franchise my brother has
finally been subjected to a Twilight
movie thank you for that a long-standing
record broken finally broken I cannot
explain the chills of excitement I have
for that as you know I have loved the
Twilight movies for how enjoyably bad
they were except for the last one that
can brighten hell and we finally have
this one the Breaking Dawn Part 2 which
is by far the crowning achievement of
absolute horridness I'll take your word
for that having not seen the other one
it is like okay so the first one I
always said was like the most enjoyably
bad and then they serve get less
enjoyable in how bad they are like
they're just unpleasant but this one
goes right back to how batshit crazy
stupid idiotic bland flat and it goes to
all new levels it's unbuttoned I I was
very excited by how bad it was oh you're
right you were very excited it was like
it was me and uncle yo and Skitch and
why ruler of time predict coumarine was
with us yeah and I'm sure he's gonna go
back to base camp or whatever and report
that pretty much it was like seven guys
who went into this seven guys swallowing
their pride walking in like manly men
and lots of beginning while by here and
sing seven tickets for Twilight please
it was okay you know
those mystery science they are those
three little a-holes that's in front of
the screen and make fun the movie
imagine seven of those guys cuz we would
not shut the hell up
oh I'm surprised we weren't ejected from
ya know like we just would Josh shut the
hell up but it's impossible
to this movie is so rude this video was
the worst he was on my right and he is
shouting at the screen just every second
he thought what he thinks I'm sorry he
thinks I had to change it to be shouts
oh no he literally was trying to will
characters to die on screen he was
sitting there going to have emotion die
just die die die die no die no I'm
literally not exaggerating this is how
loud he's shouting in the middle of a
quiet scene just die die and then when
he realized he was being too loud he
would like it soft you just got back Tai
Chi I of I don't please die okay but you
know me we can talk about but you're not
gonna have much contact unless you know
a little bit about the story which of
course with Rob seeing how he has seen
none of the films except this one would
be more than happy to explain what huh
it's going to just do your best
I think it'll be funnier if you add your
vibe um okay how do you explain this
movie um there's this girl who is kind
of hot until she talks and then the
hotness levels drop drastic um who I
guess is a vampire because her eyes are
red and she can move like the flash and
has like Superman power and exploits it
to ultimate extremes I mean literally
like they have to go get a book it's
like a choke choke like she's back as I
said dude you could have just want they
didn't do this in the other movies every
second they're speeding up the film and
it looks like a Benny Hill sketch it's
really crazy she's a vampire but like
she feeds on animals because she's a
nice vampire I don't know you method
that the tofu vampires that I forgot to
explain well the toe fan pyre yeah
pretty much
um so she's a toe fan pyre um or or
she's she eats only cougars which and
you look like that okay
um oh she is currently married yet still
looks like she's dating um James Franco
I think is what he looks like to me like
if you crossed the new spider-man dude
with James Franco you've mesh them
together and his name is
Edward um he's a vampire too and then
they have some weird freaky alien baby
that grows up insanely fast like Spock
in Star Trek 3 it's I don't know that
forest is like the Genesis forest but
this baby who is CGI a CGI babe they
could not afford a baby in this and it
is the worst there's a lot of bad
effects this is the worst effect this CG
baby it looks like that baby on the baby
food labels they just cut it out and
pasted it oh no you know it is really
sleepier than that damn baby that's
Hawking the the e-trade yeah it looks
like a baby above the Toni toné maggot
adult boys it'll be up no dude no you
guys are we gonna eat you look more
convincing yeah take that and make it
even creepier
it doesn't do I know here's what kills
me is just like okay here's our plan um
let's see we need a baby
um let's pay some woman like dirt-cheap
to borrow her baby cuz not only we have
to pay the baby by the line or let's pay
a bunch of digital artists millions of
dollars to create a CGI bin come on but
you saw the effects twenty of dehl okay
- yeah tens and tens of dollars to make
this watch our Twilight is a big-budget
because we've all know the effects in
these movies have been unbelievable and
it's creepy and I guess like there's a
scene or two where I get white it is
like oh well they want the baby like
touch Edwards or touch her her cheek or
something like okay no baby's hand you
can see a hand okay that's okay not a
whole baby they see jus the hell you
could have gotten a sack of flour and
pasted a baby Gerber baby face I don't
work in more realistic they should have
got like one of those like you know
dolls even think so okay so there's this
baby grows up really fast you have no
idea how long it take where this was
like a week or a year or heck maybe is
happening in real time with the
dissolves you don't know it's too many
Flintstones vitamins I think ten million
strong and growing and growing and
growing and holy shit you're really tall
um but so yeah so then there's a baby
and then um the other dude that I guess
she was dating at some point a Slater
from Saved by the Bell
that's what he looks like to me at
Jacob yeah I I just called him Slater
like whether he walks in and I was like
oh it's late and every time he walks in
all the girls the audience go oh um so I
guess he kind of like has custody of
this child or there was a kidnapping and
an Amber Alert was issued but nobody
cared and he brings the child back like
hey you know check her out and like
you're checked her out yes he's like oh
you're the mother so like you need to
get attached but but but not too long
cuz you may eat her something I don't
get that but because the child is like
could be an immortal like there's a
bunch of nasty ass vampires wearing way
too much like clown makeup and like
opera get up in like Italy somewhere
well led by Andy Serkis I mean it's not
really Andy Serkis but really I actually
I was think I was like who that dude
look like who he looks like like Andy
Serkis crossed with like Napoleon with
like Snape hair yeah like you know from
Harry Potter and he's all like I want
this child because I'm going to assemble
some group of like vampiric else man
he's Chris Kattan from goth talk yeah
okay I'm going to go then steel so he so
like I guess there's some cousin there's
like a really bad vampire Thanksgiving I
as a resigned a good time like some
cousins is like oh you have like some
creepy baby that's growing up as I'm
gonna report you to Chris Kattan and the
authorities or whatever and and so they
go and then they're just like oh well
Chris Kattan is gonna go they find out
news like Oh evil Napoleon Chris Kattan
is gonna kill us so here's what I'm
gonna do we have to convince this guy
that were really like cool and it's not
an immortal child I guess what happens
is according to this mythology I could
even follow an immortal vampires
basically like if some baby kids
something turns then it's like you've
got a vampire it's like five years old
so well if you have like a five year old
vampire it's like having a five year old
God like whatever it gets pissed this is
gonna go nuts why vampires would give a
shit about this I don't know but it's
like even though we have this
army of small children we could have
that would go batshit crazy for us and
kill everybody no we don't want them do
that so we're just gonna kill the child
and the parents and anybody else related
in a weird Sleepy Hollow style flashback
that involves decapitations and setting
people on fire and it okay so and so so
pretty much like going to get all these
other vampires ones that would make much
more interesting windows no no this is
the weird thing like so they go and they
assemble basically a Captain Planet team
of vampires it's like yeah we got
Amazonians we got Indians oh we got
Africans hells yeah we got African oh
and they have the powers of the cat's
implanted characters that's why it's
like before fire with water no guards
under glitter powers assemble like yeah
it was like and this serves no purpose
in the movie for them to have these
powered Stephenie Meyer made this shit
up for no reason if you took that out of
the movie nothing would change here's
the funny thing like I'm watching these
like why are you doing this cuz if they
have this conversation she's like do you
realize what evil Chris Kattan goth talk
guy is doing he is assembling this evil
group of like x-men vampires so he wants
the child because the child has some
sort of superpower it's like Superman
Returns or something I guess is this
child isn't so he wants to take the
child no matter what so what are we
going to do
ah I know exactly we're gonna do we're
going to get a bunch of witnesses to
prove that the child is really a super
child and not immortal so that way he
will be convinced and we won't have to
fight him well but wait won't he want to
steal the child then yes uh-huh and they
never got farther than that plan cuz
like I'm watching this I'm like what did
they think was going to happen now there
isn't out it's really helpful I like
there they they do come up with a
solution that is so freakin stupid I
like I do we tell it like should we
spoiler alert
don't want free me like the big and then
yeah okay okay we will get the ending
game were fighting right now spoiler
okay so that the ending hall will get to
the end ESA the ending is a category all
its own it is a
had a great science at school and study
we'll get to the ending in a minute
hurricane sandy of climate I say let's
first talk about we'll just talk about
real fast just like you know so are the
problems and what we thought of
everything else in the movie and stuff
like that and then we'll get to the
client well the intro was weird cuz it
was like put together by like I felt
like I was watching like some ad for
Colorado like Alpine Skiing gone wrong
when I got all the movies well I just
well okay I haven't seen all the other
movies it's like here's how these shots
of the mountains in like blood red and
I'm just like it's Bram Stoker's Alaska
I didn't so basically here's the thing
so you got the dumbass characters with
the dumbass motivations the only two
characters I've ever liked in any of
these films one is Jacob who's still the
only supportive good human being despite
being a werewolf in this they still get
shit on the whole thing with the imprint
thing which before I was er making the
argument of oh wait no he's doing that
to save the kid's life you know it's
almost like he's making a sacrifice you
know and I guess in this one they're
playing up more eats like talking every
like should I call you dad or something
I'm like oh don't do that it's like that
one take the creek valuations he had the
brawny man okay okay and the dead the
dad is the only other character that's
ever been you know like a decent human
being but by god he is so fucking stupid
in this like they make him so dumb like
okay so Jacob comes forward and shows
him that he's a werewolf which you know
he sorta just back and goes huh alright
yeah okay no no I'm gonna bring this up
cuz this was the strangest paced film
ever because so one base so many things
happen in this film that it scenes are
only 30 seconds long like because they
have to cram so much stuff in which
makes me wonder what the hell was in
part one or a or or Breaking Dawn like
you know one point a lot of vampire sex
it was at it because I'm just lazy wait
what happened
it's her because you've been part of
this unless you know about your minds of
the Damned Harry Potter movie where was
like movie seven-one-seven a or whatever
had nothing it was like The Blair Witch
Project you know with the three Hogwarts
kids so it was like I guess he's crammed
all this crap in the sack
one yeah and that's yeah the vanilla
touching that because that happens
there's this scene where like Slater
walks in he's like hey Bella's dad I'm
gonna show you something for your own
protectors like what and he's like bro
I'm a giant dog isn't it like this in
any other well-directed film would have
been a big moment where he's like oh my
god and you would show his reactions
like oh crap instead it's just like he
just jumps out huh huh
and it's like poo though let's talk I
think other memory and he's just like I
just saw something like I mean it's like
it thumbs out his daughter is alive
which by the way Bella and Edward were
totally go along the way shows did they
faked their own deaths cuz I didn't know
it's like he didn't know I there it's go
go they were gonna go along with the
idea of making him think she was dead
which fucking dicks okay it's like what
we don't want to risk his life it's like
he thinks you're fucking dead it's like
this is a constant thing in these movies
where it's like I don't wanna risk our
life you're making the person's like
Mars other Potter did that that was like
the most offensive thing I thought in
the seventh the first of the seventh
films like like when she's like I'm just
gonna erase their memories cuz I mean
that's like that's like a horrible
horrible thing okay jump the fuck up
okay focus well no it's the focus is
here because same thing who better the
so Bella did that benjai baby Bella a
horrible horrible truck yeah why and
here's the thing okay so he come sees
that Bella is still alive they can't
tell him that she's a vampire to again
protect him somehow I don't get it but
he comes there knows when we'll hunt him
down yeah you know knows werewolves
exist you know so he's just like what
the hell's going on she says I can't
tell you but I can to assure you that
it's for your own good and everything's
alright it's like okay it's like no this
is a conversation why did he feel great
werewolf thing then if yeah cuz she was
houses she's a werewolf yeah why not
just say that
I mean there's so many other end you
know what that's offensive to him like
you know that she doesn't trust him I
mean and like I said this is the only
other like decent human being and then
they constantly send them off on trips
he's like oh okay do Peter Peter be like
never questions anything that's why you
look amazing ever come back I don't know
we never see
mostly characters that they build in
this movie you never see at the very end
jacob disappears practically at the end
the daughter I think sort of does too
okay okay okay so you have all this dumb
shit going on you have oh you know these
other vampires come in which will make
much more interesting movies uh there
they're there to bear witness so so
they're on the side of like the you know
they want protect the girl pretty much
the immortal Bela whatever by testifying
in her good name cuz that's gonna work
okay so uh so bottom I I mean with
everything else the acting is horrendous
the Scimitar Phe gets a little good as
well as the music uh but the logic and
all that stuff everything that made the
first one so enjoyably dumb is in the
first two thirds of this movie now this
is where we get into spoilers if you
don't want to know don't watch it I
think you know what our opinion is but
we have to talk about the last third of
this week this last third just like
exceeds the expectations of stupid you
just you leave knowing you okay okay we
clear so alright so you got all the bad
vampires lined up you know the people I
go if you want to see this spectacularly
awful ending for yourself without it
being spoiled turn this review over yeah
I mean that this is point over Turner I
didn't like the movie also that much for
you just so you know where I'm coming
from
it was pretty look at but that was about
it and what were your thoughts quickly
before we go it's so enjoyable dumb now
it has to be what it was laughably bad
but it was so enjoyable money to see
that I am something to see this because
this was like that well I I loved it for
how bad it was this was back to formula
for the twilights for me for how
enjoyably bad they are but let's get
into this layout code now let's get to
the climax so all the bad vampires are
lined up you know like the extras from
Eyes Wide Shut do you know with the
masks everything you know the hoods this
is a gladiator it's like this is like
one long line you've all dudes dressed
in like black cloaks and then another
robe like you're scrappy Captain Planet
you know wondered yes I see and you got
so the good vampires and the good
werewolves there too and they go in the
Andy Serkis vampire having it up like my
god
okay like Matt like the funniest line of
the movie we couldn't stop laughing I
thought we were gonna get kicked up yeah
I thought I'd lay beyond he what what
sets it on there was some line no no
it's when they bring the girl down
because the girl apparently could touch
people and show them that oh that's the
truth that she really is immortal or
whatever or she's not the one I don't
know she's cool pretty something said so
oh shit she she comes out honey
yeah he sees he sees the child first he
goes oh the Shire and child kid yeah
yeah everyone's the child comes forward
and he looks at her and just suddenly
out of nowhere we're not even
exaggerating this idea in unison okay
yeah one two three oh really make that
sound if I think we're doing it subtly
sound it is the sound like a drunk makes
when he's having a really really good
piss like he's been holding it in for
hours ooh he's pretty busy Oh standing
up here and all just like oh we just
lose it I think the rest of theatre
starts laughing to it this is just like
Karl's lamp was the best he just goes so
inside does that any says you know so he
for whatever reason lets out this
dumbass laugh we go near the line after
because I was so silly and then and it's
he's okay and but they starts arguing
what if this child who yes is very
powerful is not immortal is very
powerful can still kill and is a danger
should we still get rid of this child
room I'm thinking we sure yeah for
something it's supposed to be the
villain he's very much like no I will
listen bring folio witnesses tight house
awaiting with that also game with him I
get you like as I like that but I just
was weird is he a villain or none you've
rat you basically you've no know anyone
that goes my eyes avail you yeah but
you've had an hour and a half of
build-up and this guy is very much not
that villainous when all things are
considered like I'm just doing it for
the best of my kind and this is like I
want you to assemble a team of awesome
vampires like that's pretty cool I would
probably be with this guy so okay so and
then Alice who I guess is a vampire that
can actually show people the future gets
visions of
interesting thing I didn't realize um
vampires are like the planeteers they
can like control the elements and know
how the x-men the planet or novia oh I'm
sorry your power now to vampires that
yeah Bella has like some like shield
power invisible woman shield whatever
that is yeah and like it was some dude
killing control the elements like Laura
Stephenie Meyer made-up shit I did yeah
you know what all I'm gonna say is this
Mormons have a very interesting take on
mythology that's all I can sir not
insult Mormons that way just Stephenie
Meyer okay Stephanie Mary and let's keep
the focus again but about okay we should
get to the climate we're delaying it
here okay so Alice goes up I think
that's her name and it says I can show
you that the child is not a danger and
you know everything Nita yeah come here
oh he grants her hand you know gets the
vision goes off oh and she says oh my
god no matter what we do you're gonna
want to kill the kid he goes yep okay
pretty much there's just a giant waste
of time so this giant battle all these
vampires lined up oh good vampires and
the werewolves on the other hand side it
is like the most epic battle is I'm
running towards eternal musicals and
they attention aspects I pursue the most
unbelievable over-the-top battle you've
ever seen in your life
there's a girl a friend ego who's
explosion suck Norris drops from the sky
decapitate is left and right I mean hey
dogs and cats living together mass
hysteria the werewolves are jumping on
top of the other thing and weird and
Bella are like you know like I said to
doing gymnastics like you know what
they're using each other like the Wonder
Twins like I would take my jaw hit the
ground I'm like I was applauding I'm
like yes yes like we're getting into
this we're like holy shit this is really
stupid but a strand of honest Oh God
real this one kid that one winner who
controls the elements slam dismiss into
the ground the ground breaks okay big
rock
strolling in what it's like that size
ghostbusters when they nearly got signs
up by the stream there are sorts of
levels of Awesome and when somebody dies
they set them on fire set off fire going
on I am and I haven't seen this many
decapitations and severed little sense
like the Jedi battle and Attack of the
Clones yeah
body parts flying off lemon just over
the place and the most weirdest
incredible stunt and it's so goofy and
people making the weirdest pages
character actor character actor
character getting killed off if this
were an anime oh my god this would be
like I really felt like a Kira
Evangelion like all role it was just
this incredible fuckin battle yeah I
mean unbelievable and it ends with you
know the gone wrong that guy he gets his
Henry hump like Bella Edward you know
and they look down you know and his
severed head and still alight his eyes
are blinking stuff and she gets the fire
the only badass a moment of looks at him
start setting the fire towards him and
then he threw out none of it happened
cut cut to her cut to the vampire chick
who could show him things like this and
he's sitting there's like whoa and she
like steps like she's like that's what
will happen if you decide to oppose us
and so we went ballistic
I mean first time audience started
laughing like almost Insley like even
the audience for my glasses the people
at MIT who wanted to see this we like
literally tossed our empty cups of beer
shouted oh it was an audience cracked up
they could not believe
go to hell movies go to hell
while I could not believe that while I
did something this stupid a horrible
dream it was all a dream and it's like
and the bad guy just see you know in the
vision he sees all this happiness goes
oh okay Tata and they take off like a
Benny Hill sketch I think you may be
right
of course you could have just force-fed
me that thing but I'm gonna buy it one
way or another
totally Piske he heads out Bella and
Edward live happily ever after the end
you know what I love though what made
the story so um so powerful is the fact
that not a single person had to
sacrifice one damn thing not one day was
like I think also to a full house
everything wrapped up and I ran in on
them I think get axed off that's what
who gave a shit jammed and ran it on her
yeah I mean if anything it's a morality
tale you know hey don't be don't rush in
you don't be a dick vampire Thanksgiving
so and yeah not a single nobody else
sacrifice anything he's mean and like
here's the thing the actors have no
chemistry like I'm watching was like no
you're right though it's if except for
Slater he yeah he's only likable care he
was pay okay he was passable much like
Slater and Saved by the Bell
he was passable and here's the thing
okay so you got all these take out all
these are the characters that would have
been enjoyed take out the daughter who
should be the most fascinating character
in all the movie gets something like
three lines take out Dakota Fanning who
I think gets two lines
take out this story that has a ton of
logical surveilling every iota for my
light was creepy old Dakota Fanning even
creepier she's only gonna creepier and
take out all that stuff take out all the
things that usually make a twilight
phone bad this ending that suddenly
gives you something actually awesome in
Twilight and then tells you that it was
Super Mario Brothers to that shit never
happened it is its own fucking catechol
Super Mario Brothers two of vampire
movie it is it's the dumbest most
insulting resolution though it was
fucking ever know what's going Bella
picked up a giant turn up and defeated
wart like yeah she could fly to those
interests yeah puzzle no she can't fly
oh yeah that's right
actually she and she kind of doesn't
like there's an opening see where she
hops of the mama and it was pretty much
like Princess Peach in supersu
susceptibilities ain't attending it so
you can see why we have to talk about it
because something that awesome and yet
totally ruined
it's like Twilight almost had something
awesome in it something still dumb but
awesomely dumb and it just totally threw
it in the crapper does
how could anyone think that would work
the equivalent of having the twist at
the end of Empire Strikes Back after all
of that be Luke wakes up and goes oh oh
my god what did I don't tell what was it
was a dynasty was that the one where
it's like the last couple seasons were a
dream or something oh yeah
that guy should have just cut to Patrick
Duffy but yeah in the shower I mean it's
really like that it was the most
insulting thing you could throw even at
Twilight fans it is Twilight know even
ATS why I think is even the audience
there was laughing and they didn't need
us to boo it like they were giggling
even when they saw that none of that was
happy that was all a vision this
unbelievable this woman's worldview is
very I will say that it's very
fascinating yeah that she wanted to get
out all this violence all this evil a
song she just says oh but it did happen
I gave her that okay a very fascinating
point of view like I can take that away
from her I don't think anyone else on
the planet has the same point of view
that this woman does know but so many
tweenage girls wish they did it's so
okay we should I guess we should wrap
this up um I my the only positive thing
I can say for it is well the music's
pretty good it's Carter Burwell so you
know it's serviceable and I I will say
this the one thing in the movies defense
it is gorgeous
say they make it look good
cinematography in this film is really
good but as young as lewis has always
been in the cinematography this they
they make it look pretty not my only
problem with that those like okay so the
cinematography is great but it's kind of
like polishing a turd you know you could
go up and be like I have completely
reconstructed Michelangelo's David out
of shit well still that that's that's
awesome like that's a really nice
sculpture but it's still shit and it's
the same thing here it's like the
cinematography is gorgeous but it's
still crap like it's we need girls would
still enjoy it I know I'm not a tween
age girls all i know is i am a man above
30 who ended up seeing Twilight and I
didn't get it get a lame boy this way if
you don't like the Twilight movies this
one's not gonna sway you but if you
enjoy them for how awesome we like to
take action debates is a good swing but
but if you enjoy how ridiculously
enjoyably bad they are this is the Opus
this is the how could they make these
decisions I will neither them it's
really bad and I did laughs I just don't
get what's hang money to see it yeah
there's not only here or scotch and I
did both I have waiting for Stephan
Pires
to come out and just be like you know oh
good no this was all just a social
satire this character I was playing that
was sugary Finn's oh you had these don't
really have vampires are I sure do you
know nobody did it with the ending she
you know what she did she's wick rolled
us yeah yeah damn thing is one big rifle
just rickrolled us in the last 30
minutes of this film it's so it's it's
really something to see in my opinion it
is so spectacularly bad I laughed all I
can say I can say without a shadow that
I've never seen anything like it
it's it's really like thinking about no
never seen anything like hopefully you
can sort of read from that whether or
not this will be up your alley or not uh
so god that's all I can of us in the
seven was is like I'm with team shut the
fuck up and get off screen so I that's
all I got man any parting words I you
know I spent years avoiding it and now I
know that was time well spent and I'll
never be able to get that two hours of
my life you did see the absolute
enjoyably worst of it so yeah at least
if you could see why you saw the best of
the worst I know yeah I'm better for
having seen that okay so okay guys thank
you so much and we will see you next
review I hate you yeah
you